what i want to do in this video is give
ourselves a framework for thinking about
the rent
versus buy decision for a home
and the key takeaway i hope you have
after this video is there's not just a
simple right answer that it's always
better to rent or that it's always
better to buy for full disclosure i own
a house and i bought it for a whole
series of reasons some of them emotional
some of them potentially economic but
there's and but it depends on your
personal context where you are in your
life and what part of the world you live
in and what the economy is doing at that
moment what rents are versus what
housing prices are and hopefully this
video will give you a framework for at
least how to think about them so let's
say this house is on the market and it's
on the market for a rental at 1500 a
month
so 1500
per
month which is the same thing as 18 000
a year
18 000
a year so that's one option that you
haven't let's say there's an identical
neighboring house that's on the market
for sale
and you are in a position to buy it
let's say that house is
four hundred thousand dollars is the
price that you can get it at
you don't have 400 000 so you're gonna
have to borrow some money you've saved
you've saved a hundred thousand for your
down payment hundred thousand
down payment
down
payment
and so you're going to have to take the
remainder out as a loan
so you're going to take out a 300
300 000
loan
now a traditional mortgage one that has
a fixed term maybe it's a 15-year fixed
mortgage or 30-year fixed mortgage it's
your
every month you pay your your mortgage
bill and some of it goes to in a
traditional mortgage some of it goes
towards the loan
and some of it goes to or some of it
goes to pay down the interest
and the rest of it will go down to pay
down the loan so for example let's say
that your mortgage payment is 1800
hundred per month
early on it might be disproportionately
interest it might be say fifteen hundred
a month in interest and three hundred
dollars to actually pay down your loan
to actually pay down this 300 000 loan
and then as that loan is paid down near
the end of the term of your mortgage
it might have gone the other way where
each month you're paying much more to
pay down your loan maybe by that point
it's 1500
and the interest since your its interest
on a lower amount by that much because
you've paid down the loan so much your
interest might be lower so this would be
kind of a traditional process of of a
traditional mortgage but to simplify our
analysis i'll assume that you're taking
an interest only loan a loan where
you're only required to pay the interest
portion of it and you could pay down
your loan as you want to so let's say
that this is interest only this is going
to help just simplify things and
obviously if we want to get really
detailed we'd probably have to get a
spreadsheet out to really analyze things
and see how the interest and the
how the interest payment changes as we
go
through the life of the loan but let's
assume it's interest only
at six percent
six percent interest
interest only at six percent interest
and so that means on an annual basis
you're going to pay eighteen thousand in
interest
eighteen thousand in interest six
percent of three hundred thousand
eighteen 000 in interest now depending
where you live and what your income
level is in a lot of places you can
deduct you can deduct mortgage interest
from your income and so this doesn't
mean that you get all of the eighteen
thousand back this is saying if you're
making a hundred thousand a year instead
of paying say thirty percent on a
hundred thousand you're now going to pay
your taxes on a hundred thousand minus
eighteen thousand so it'll your your
taxable income would go down to 82 000
and so you'll save roughly your tax rate
as a percentage of this so let's say you
save roughly a third of this on reduced
taxes
so that's reduced taxes
and so your effective interest that
you're paying after the tax break let's
say it's twelve thousand dollars
twelve thousand dollars is out of pocket
or the effective
effective
cost of interest
cost
of
interest
and we're not done we know that there
are things there's there are costs of
home ownership you'll have to pay
usually some type of property tax let's
say it's one percent property tax one
percent of four hundred thousand would
be four thousand
four thousand in property tax
property tax
and you of course have to upkeep the
house maybe you have maybe you're you
you have a gardener maybe you maybe you
have to repair things you get things
painted who knows what it might be these
are things that you usually would not
have to pay if you're renting and so
let's say although it might be different
once again depending on the situation
let's say there's 2 000 a year 2 000 per
year in upkeep
and upkeep now the reason why i listed
all of these things and obviously we
could go into more depth and more detail
and think about other things and and
they're more particular to different
circumstances but this is a list in
either of these cases or the things that
are essentially are are going out the
door if you're renting that eighteen
thousand dollars a year that's just
going out the door that's that's that's
the what you have to pay for the benefit
of living in this house
if you buy the things that are just
going out the door are your effective
cost of interest your property tax your
upkeep and so this will all uh this will
all add up to let's see four thousand
plus two thousand is six thousand plus
twelve thousand is eighteen thousand
18 000.
so just like that it looks like our
annual costs that are just going out the
door given the assumptions in every
different circumstance you're going to
have different assumptions so this is
just a framework your
what's going out the door what's going
out the door is eighteen thousand
dollars a year in either case
but we are not done yet in this case we
didn't talk about what we're doing with
our hundred thousand dollars over here
we had to use it far down payment over
here we still have a hundred thousand
dollars invested
100 000
invested so we're gonna get some income
from this hundred thousand that we
wouldn't have gotten here and it depends
what we're doing with it if we have it
in a really safe bank account maybe
we're getting one percent or two percent
but maybe we're investing it in a
portfolio of things and getting four
percent or who knows what what we're
doing here but we need to think about
what we could have gotten from that down
payment from that from investing this
incremental money so let's just say for
the sake of argument that you get a two
percent return
at two percent
annual
annual return so you're getting two
thousand dollar
two thousand dollars in investment
income
investment income
from that hundred thousand dollars so
your actual out of pocket if you were to
net your you net your your income
benefit
that you didn't have to or the the
investment return that you didn't have
to use up on the down payment that
netted against your rent now you're
sixteen thousand
now you're sixteen thousand out of
pocket
sixteen thousand cost per year
now the way that i rigged the numbers
for this video it turns out that for
this individual purely on the economics
purely for this year as we'll talk about
in a few seconds things might change in
the ensuing years
but purely for this year if we can
assume these numbers it actually might
make sense to rent a house and of course
this this this analysis completely
changes depending on how these numbers
change if this house were cheaper if you
got lower interest whatever it might be
now all of a sudden this number might
look better if the rent was a lot higher
this number would look similarly would
not look as good if your return on
investing weren't that good this number
would this number would be higher and it
would not it would not look as good so
the key thing to realize is is just try
to analyze what your actual
out-of-pocket costs are and one might
say well look you know just
psychologically when i'm doing this
mortgage at least it's forcing me it's
forcing me to save and that's true it is
kind of a forced saving that's happening
here but in but in theory you could do
it here the equivalent amount that you
would have paid for interest or the the
interest portion of your loan that's
your rent and above and beyond that you
could just save that 300
a month and put it into your investment
pool and after 30 years you might very
well have a good amount of money there
collecting a lot of or generating a lot
of income so there's no very clear cut
answer that renting is always better
than buying or that buying is always
better than renting it really depends on
the circumstances this is a back of the
envelope version in future videos we'll
do a more in-depth version
but the other things that we should
think about beyond just the numbers are
the intangibles and so let's just think
about those in a second let's think
about the intangibles that favor renting
and the intangibles that favor buying
so the biggest reason and this is why we
bought a house a few years ago is from
buying their stability
there is stability you might get a great
deal on a rental and the owner takes
care of it and it's in a great
neighborhood but maybe they want to rent
it out to someone else or maybe they
want to
maybe they want to move into the house
themselves and then you've got to move
if you buy a house as long as you pay
the mortgage or you pay off the house
now pay pay off the house eventually
you're pretty much and you can pay that
and you you can pay the property taxes
and things you're pretty much guaranteed
that you can stay there
another reason that you might want to
buy is rents are unpredictable rents
could go up
rents
could
go up if you're in a really rapidly
rental appreciating market save some
place like manhattan or san francisco
it's nice to be able to say oh look i
got a fixed mortgage payment this is
what i got to pay once i pay this thing
down i don't have to worry about the
craziness of what rents might do because
the economy is because so many people
want to live wherever wherever your your
house might be and then another thing
and once again this isn't an exhaustive
list is that you can customize and you
can make improvements
back when my family was renting i can't
tell you how many places we saw that
looked really nice if they just changed
this bathroom a little bit or if they
just changed that kitchen a little bit
or if they did not paint that one wall
yellow and so when you buy a house you
can make those same improvements but all
the intangibles aren't just on the
buying side
they can also be on the rental side if
you're just settling down in an area and
you want to figure out the lay of the
land you might not want to commit to one
neighborhood or one house without
understanding things better and so you
might want to have the flexibility
flexibility of renting to keep buying
and selling houses there's a lot of
costs involved especially when the cost
of of the brokerage fees and whatnot and
so you might like the flexibility you
get into a six month lease one year
lease once you understand things then
you might want to buy a house or then
you might want to rent in another
neighborhood and as we saw earlier in
the in the kind of
2003-2008 period sometimes you have
housing bubbles and sometimes these
economics go way out of whack and
housing is just overpriced
housing
overpriced relative
relative to
housing is overpriced relative to rent
so once again big takeaway it all
depends on the context but hopefully
this gives you a little bit of a
framework for thinking about the rent
versus buy decision